so everybody uh
when i never met in person i never met
jordan peterson in person
but i said to him when we met right
before
lunch
something that is said to me by so many
people who meet me for the first time i
feel like i know you
and i that is the highest compliment in
in effect i now understand what a
compliment that is when i receive it
because i never gave it to somebody
before you
and
i i have watched you for hours
and listened to you
and read your book and in fact i didn't
just read your book i heard your book
from you
so i want to tell you something without
embarrassing you
but i think i i
like to you open your heart and your
mind and so do i
when i was very young i realized that
god or nature had given me
what i have called a goodness detector
and i knew i always knew
when i was in the presence of a good
person
because that's all i really care about
i think brains are wildly overrated
wildly
uh that's why i think you you're not
bright if you join mensa
uh why you would want to announce to the
world your iq
is so bizarre to me that i
i i i'm sure there are nice people there
but i i don't understand it
but i always picked up
that and i've and i've always been right
i it's a it's a i'm batting a thousand
essentially
and when i heard you read your book
the passion
comes from i just want to help people
lead a better life
and it's really it's it's it's quite
overwhelming you you didn't just read
that book you
i won't say you sang it but
i like that you use music i'm very much
into music too
so this is the man that i'm
[Music]
honored to have this dialogue with
because you're out everybody knows
you're bright
but i know you're good
so i wanted to state that at the outset
[Applause]
[Music]
something to say about that
good
[Music]
that's good
see i don't think it's true
i mean this is why
i got motivated to do
what i've been doing and i've been doing
what i've been doing for i would say
since about 1979
in one form or another because things
take a long time to generate
and one of the things i learned in the
early 80s was that
people have a great capacity for evil
and i didn't really understand that
of myself
until
the early 80s something like that after
meditating on it for a long time
and
so i would say
it's not that i'm
i would never claim to be good
i think it's dangerous
but
i did become terrified of how terrible i
could be
and i mean i became terrified about how
terrible human beings could be and
that's one thing but that's easy it's
easy to confuse that with other human
beings
you know it's a different thing to
understand that it's true of yourself
i often recommend to my students that
they read history as a perpetrator and
not as a victim or a hero
and people very seldom do that and it's
no wonder
but i would say perhaps that i became
terrified enough from learning what i
learned that
i tried
to avoid the pathways that lead people
to the dark places that they go
and there's something in that that might
approximate good
yeah it does approximate good i i
i would agree with that
[Applause]
the parallels
between us are so eerie to me
that in my book on happiness which came
out in 99
i actually have a chapter
on the necessity of having a tragic view
of life
and then i hear you speak of like just
now this tragic view of life
and ironically if you don't have that
you can't be happy
so it's just another example of of of
this and that you're getting this
message out
if you want to comment than that please
if not i'll go on i i you you are such
an i watch you and you're such an
intense listener i don't know when
you're going to react
so
if you well there's this old idea
you knew you all know this idea
um
it's an idea
that's expressed for example in the
classic disney movie classic disney
movie which i really like
called pinocchio
and you know when pinocchio is
attempting to
free himself from
the forces that manipulate him as a
puppet and to become
an autonomous being
he is required to go to the darkest
place
to find the worst
the worst monster and face that
voluntarily
and in doing so he rescues his father
and that's a very old idea
um
i i don't know how old it is
it's
it's it's one of the oldest ideas we
have in written form and and there's no
doubt that in its pre-written form it
would be tens of thousands of years
older than that and it's a very strange
idea that you have to
journey to the darkest abyss to free the
spirit of your father
but there's a reason for it and it has
to do with the tragic view of life
which is that
you can't
discover
what you're capable of
being or withstanding and those are the
same things
without
if you hide away from any of the things
about life that are terrible but true
and and and the reason you can't
discover
who you are
without doing that is that only
necessity will force that out of you
and it i mean that
i mean that
from the perspective of learning if you
go work in a palliative care ward
you'll learn to deal with death
you'll learn the
the psychological strategies necessary
the
the steps you'll become more informed
but it's deeper than that even
we know now from a biological
perspective that
if you put yourself in new situations in
new and challenging situations
that new genes turn on in your nervous
system and code for new proteins that
produce new neurological structures and
so
you can't even be what you are fully
biologically unless you expose yourself
to everything that you can expose
yourself to as you
journey through life the the old idea of
uh
pilgrimage
was predicated on
on that idea as is walking the
um
in short cathedral the
the labyrinth
the idea that you walk the labyrinth in
in chartres you come to the center is
that you traverse every corner of the
world
quarter by quarter
and then you come to the center
and the center is the center of the
church and it's the center of the
crucifixion it's the center of suffering
and
you can't get to what that center
signifies without having journeyed
everywhere
and so
the tragic view of life is necessary
because it puts you on the journey that
reveals to yourself who you could be if
you were courageous as courageous as you
could be and as truthful as you could be
and that's equivalent to discovering to
revivifying your dead father because
you are
an ancient creature in some sense and
and perhaps one with a spark of divinity
inherent in it
but you will never release that
unless you're willing to go everywhere
that you have to go
because only necessity will call that
out of you
and so you can't be
happy
you can't be complete
without
you can't know what you could withstand
you can't have any proper sense of
self-respect
unless you know what you can tolerate
and if you avoid
everything that you have reason to avoid
but should nonetheless not avoid you
won't know who you are and then you
can't live
properly
so you uh you have said on a number of
occasions
and in every on every occasion that i
have watched you say it
not a single person in the panel you
often talk on panels
not one person has ever actually reacted
to it
i totally get it
nevertheless it's one of the most
important things you regularly say
you live as if there is a god
is that correct
well people ask me if i believe in god
you know i just i i'm going to release a
podcast about that because i i answered
that question for about two hours in
australia
because people kept asking me that
question which i really don't like
i don't like that question
and so i sat and thought about it for a
good while and i tried to figure out why
and
and then i thought well
you said you believe you see
i thought
who would have the
audacity
to claim
that they believed in god
[Music]
if they examined the way they lived
who would dare say that
to to believe you think to believe in a
christian sense to actually this is why
nietzsche said there was only ever one
christian and that was christ
to have the audacity to claim that
means that you live it out fully
and that's an
that's an unbearable
task
in some sense
i just debated slavoy zizek
about a week ago although it wasn't
really much of a debate it was it was a
strange event but he said something very
brilliant and to me that justified the
entire event at least from my
perspective
he talked about
christ's moment of crisis on the cross
when he
cried out to god that he had been
forsaken and what zizik said
was that what that meant was that
the conditions of human existence are so
tragic
that even god himself in human form
lost faith for a moment in the goodness
of being
and i thought that was a remarkable
observation because
well if god himself would lose faith
under such conditions
what would you expect from normal human
beings
confronted with what we're confronted
by and
to be able to
accept
the structure of existence the suffering
that goes along with it and the
disappointment and the betrayal and and
to
nonetheless act properly right to aim at
the good
with all your heart right to to dispense
with the malevolence and your desire for
destruction and revenge and all of that
and to face things courageously and to
tell the truth
to speak the truth and to act it out
that's what it means to believe
that's what it means
it doesn't it doesn't mean to state it
it means to act it out
and unless you act it out
you should be very careful about
claiming it
and so i've never been comfortable
saying anything other than
i try to act as if god exists because
god only knows what you'd be if you
truly believed
i mean if you think about it in some
sense
that's the central idea in christianity
is that
if you were capable of believing it
would be a transfiguring event a truly
transfiguring event and i know people
experience that to one degree or another
but we have no idea what the limit of
that is and we have no idea what the
possibility is within each person if
they lived a life that was
maximally courageous and maximally
truthful
you know because maybe you're running at
sixty percent or seventy percent or
twenty percent and at cross purposes to
yourself
god only knows what you'd be if if you
believed
and so
while i act
i try to act like i believe
but i'd never claim that i manage it
because it's too it's it's a lot to
manage
properly
and you have to be careful about
claiming to manage things that you can't
manage
and so
that's part of the answer to that
question it's a great answer as it
happens
[Applause]
i'd like you to react to something that
is very operative in my life i just and
and if you
i always tell people on on my radio show
totally feel free to say sorry i really
don't don't find that uh tenable or
whatever you however you want to react
uh my my my route as an adult to god has
been completely circuitous i have come
through the the back door
i as i wrote 25 years ago how i found
god at
columbia i realized in the 70s graduate
school at columbia that i was being
taught nonsense literally nonsense
things that made no sense
and it drove me crazy because they were
all bright bright people taught me
nonsense
one day walking through colombia
the only time i ever had i wouldn't say
i never had a theophany but i did have
an epiphany
all of a sudden one of the verses from
my yeshiva education in brooklyn new
york the cloistered orthodox world of my
childhood and i don't use cloistered and
i don't like closter but i'm not using
it in a pejorative way i'm just
explaining what i had
and all of a sudden one of the verses
that we said every morning in
kindergarten first grade and second
grade
for the first time since second grade
came to my brain
wisdom begins with fear of the lord
changed my life
there's no wisdom at columbia because
there's no god at columbia
and that has been
that is one of the ways i knew oh
without god look what happens without
god look what happens morally
intellectually in terms of wisdom and i
my biggest reasons for belief in god
are watching what happens when people
don't
so i'd love to have your reaction
is it c s lewis was it c.s lewis who
said that
if you cease to believe in god you'll
start to believe in anything
that was uh um the the british
chesterton yeah thank you right yeah
yeah well that's that's a
that's a good that's a good way of
looking at it
i mean if
catholicism you know
i've gone through lots of catholic
cathedrals in europe and of course
they're stunning creations and but
they're
gothic and strange and the doctrine is
eerie and
and
complex and
surreal
and and the biblical writings are the
same
you think of a book like revelation for
example
but i think that the catholicism that's
as sane as people can get
you know
broadly speaking is that
you
we need a metaphysic
a narrative metaphysic to hold us
together
and it has to be
predicated on something that's
transcendent and absolute
and and if you lose that then you'll
fall for something else
you'll fall for something else
or you'll fall for nothing which is
which is no better
and i learned that from reading
nietzsche and i learned that from
reading dostoevsky
and this is the problem with the
rationalists like sam harris and and and
and
the atheists dawkins
now they believe that if we dispensed
with our superstitions we'd all become
harris and dawkins
rational
beings
devoted towards the good
however we conceptualized that for
rational reasons and i don't believe
that because i don't believe that we are
rational beings fundamentally i think
we're deeply irrational it's amazing
that we can all sit in this room
together without tearing ourselves into
shreds
and i mean that it's really quite a
remarkable thing that all of us who've
come from all over north america can sit
here so peacefully and concentrate on a
single thing without any tension or
trouble
the the improbability of that should not
be underestimated
the the the unlikelihood that that might
be the case
and then
the issue of god as well is that there
has to be something of
fundamental worth
there is something that you consider of
you know what
i think that
regard for other people
for the consciousness of other people
for the conscious being of other people
is
is is in that realm
if you're going to
have a relationship with yourself if
you're going to be able to love someone
else if you're going to be able to take
care of your family and your community
you have to
attribute to human beings
and
a value that
might as well be described as divine
given that it has to be the ultimate
value that you hold
and i see
it seems to me that it's not
unreasonable to associate that value
that is intrinsic in humanity with
something that's of metaphysically
that's metaphysically real
that's part of the structure of
reality itself
and
my
sense has been
that
it's
it makes
if you watch how people act when they're
acting properly
the hypothesis that there is
divinity within us that reflects
divinity itself
is the only conclusion that makes sense
that works
and so i think the evidence
i think the evidence suggests that
you know you said you look look what
happens when societies lose their
bearings it's like
yeah you that's what convinced me
to the degree that i became a religious
person i didn't wasn't as if i
discovered god it was more like i
discovered satan and discovered the
devil and certainly believed
that very powerfully
metaphysically or not you don't have to
read that much about what happened in
nazi germany or what happened in the
soviet union or what happened in mauis
china what continues to happen in many
places around the world to be convinced
that there's a great darkness
and it seems to me that if there's a
great darkness then there has to be a
great light
and the first part of that is
true beyond any hope of refutation
and the second seems to be a logical
necessity in the light of the first
it's a powerful line that you uh you
i feel so obviously the same
i want to talk to you about the darkness
so i've often said
all of my life really
that
we
uh have a wrong metaphor in calling evil
dark because it's
it's actually so bright
that people can't stare it in the face
the number of canadian or american
students at the most prestigious
universities who could identify paul
pott or even the gulag archipelago
let alone the great leap forward in
china is so small
the knowledge of evil it is now up to
over a quarter of kids never heard of
auschwitz it'll be a half very soon it
will be three quarters in a generation
they don't know evil
i at berkeley i was had a dialogue with
two leftist students
my last question to them was do you
believe people are basically good and
they said yes
and i said
it's so demonstrably wrong that belief
that there's only one possible
explanation for why you hold it
because you live in such a good country
yeah well that's the that's the goodness
of naivete right and it's something
that's
encouraged
you know you encourage that by
producing safe spaces around people you
produce that by sheltering them you want
to preserve that childlike
innocence but once you're no longer a
child it's not childlike it's just
childish
and and that's that's not good to be a
40 year old child
and to think that people are
fundamentally good
it's it's not that
good is very difficult
it's by no means the default position
what's the default position entropy
catastrophe tragedy malevolence and
death
that's the default position the good
struggles up against that that's no easy
thing to manage
to think of that as intrinsic it's an
intrinsic possibility but it's not
something that you
it's not something that
you can manifest without faith and
commitment and and the more faith and
the more commitment the better and the
deeper the better and it's the most
difficult of things to do
and and it is
it's appalling to teach people the
alternative and i know that speaking i
can speak
of this clinically
you know
the people who are most prone to
post-traumatic stress disorder are naive
people
this is well known clinically it's
there's nothing about this that's that's
that's uh
it's questionable
or
or unorthodox
if you believe that people are basically
good and that the world
rewards
goodness with good in return if that's
your fundamental belief that there's not
really any such thing as evil
and you encounter someone malevolent
which could be yourself
well that's often what happens to people
who develop post-traumatic stress
disorder you know they're they're it's
very common that people
develop ptsd because they've done
something so
incomprehensibly morally repugnant that
it's damaged them
psychophysiologically and they cannot
recover
it's very common among soldiers it's not
what they saw although sometimes it is
it's what they did they have no
framework within which to conceptualize
it
if you have no theory of evil if you
have no theory of good and evil if you
have no metaphysics and someone
malevolent touches you
you're done
and so
telling people that
human beings are basically good and that
evil doesn't exist makes them
uh ripe fruit for the picking by the
malevolent
and there's nothing about that that's
positive
it's mere
cowardice masquerading as virtue
it's the devouring mother and from the
freudian perspective i'll keep you
innocent i'll keep you young and naive
and nothing will ever come to harm you
it's like precisely the opposite is the
case in life
that is why by the way
i truly yep
that is why
i truly believe that a 12 year old at a
traditional christian or jewish school
is wiser
and more likely to be happy than a
secular professor of philosophy who is
50 years old
just because i knew i went again to
yeshiva all so half the day in hebrew
jewish studies half the day in english
secular studies i knew at six people
were not basically good because god said
so in genesis when he decided to destroy
the world because it turned out rotten
so i knew at the earliest possible age
people were not basically good and it
not only affected my velvet my world
view it made me happy because then i
realized wow i'm meeting good people
despite the fact that people are not
basically good i really do have good
people in my life am i lucky or what
yeah yeah well that that's a that's a
really good that's a really good point
because
you see when i said that it was a
miracle that we can all sit here
peacefully right like that is how i look
at it i think every day when i walk out
into the world and it's not rack and
runes and flames and floods that it's a
bloody miracle
i mean it that we hold this together
it's not an easy thing to do and peace
to think of peace as the default
position is a form of deep insanity like
it's
it requires work to to to to maintain
peace
and you can't be properly grateful
unless you understand
how unlikely it is that
while we're not in the throes of world
war three
we're not still in the depths of world
war ii
that the cold war is mostly over
that the economic conditions of people
everywhere on the planet are improving
at a rate that's
could only be described as miraculous
and that most things are going in a
positive direction
if you assume that that's normative then
you think well that's life but
and you have no reason to
to be wide-eyed
to have your eyes wide open in
admiration and gratitude at the fact
that
the worst which has frequently
manifested itself is not
knocking at your door at this moment
because that's the story of humanity and
not peace and prosperity
so here we have it and here we should
preserve it and here we should spread it
we should do everything we can to live
in a manner that makes that most likely
and we should do that
because well you said what did you say
fear of god it's like
throughout the old testament you know
it's one story after another is that
people
develop societies and they become
arrogant and they wander off the path
and
as soon as they wander off the path all
hell breaks loose
and
if you're fortunate enough to be where
all hell isn't breaking loose you should
do everything you can to help ensure
that
we
stay the course and walk the straight
and narrow path
so i have a
[Applause]
so i have a very deep worry in light of
our absolute
unanimity if you could speak of
unanimity among two people but
we're so confident in this
this is shocking how good things are
and yet in the united states
and i i follow canada a lot but i'll
speak about america right now
in the united states half at least half
of young people think they are living in
a rotten society
sexist intolerant xenophobic homophobic
islamophobic racist bigoted
that's a six herb that's my acronym for
what i just said
this is frightening to me
and i want to know is it frightening to
you
well
you know i always try to give the devil
is due
and the
idea
that
the west is a
oppressive patriarchy
characterized by the
sins that you just described
is true
you know there's
if we look through our history personal
or
political
there's no shortage of things to be
appalled by
but that's not the question
exactly or that's not the issue
the issue is compared to what
no it was churchill
this time i've got this right
it was churchill who said that democracy
is the worst form of government
except for all the other forms of
government
and i would say that about our societies
is that
there's no
we have every reason to be awake
and cognizant of
our errors
whether they're political or economic or
personal
but
compared to how it could be
and now it has been
in many places and how it is
most
everywhere in the world and how it was
for much of the 20th century
things are so good here that it's
absolutely beyond comprehension
and so along with that
careful awareness of the flaws of the
patriarchy let's say
should be an unbelievable gratitude that
we could wake up in the morning and
the lights are on and
and the
freeways are running and
there's no starvation
directly facing us and
that our children will live
and that the probability that any one of
us will die a violent death is
negligible
and
the thing that bothers me
about one of the things that bothers me
about the modern
university
is the absolute lack of gratitude that
characterizes its teachings it's
like it's half the story you know it's
like people are oppressed by nature
and people are oppressed by culture and
people are oppressed by their own dark
nate their own dark side it's an
existential reality but you have to
you have to balance that you have to
understand that nature has its
benevolent element and that's what's
given you life and you have to be
grateful for your culture for everything
that is provided to you and you have to
understand that people can be good as
well as
adversarial and malevolent and you have
to be grateful for that and there's damn
there's a
there's there's a
there's a damnable shortage of gratitude
in the modern academy and that's based
on
a naivety or a resentment that's so deep
that it's almost incomprehen a naivety
and a resentment and a willful blindness
to the reality of history that's so deep
that it's almost incomprehensible
so
if i'm going to ask you
maybe
you may
strike who's absurd but i'm going to ask
it anyway
except for technical knowledge like
medicine or engineering
mathematics
obviously any of the natural sciences
law
if nobody went if all north americans
graduating high school decided i'm not
going to college
would the would north america be a
better or a worse place
if you took away the stem fields
yeah taking away the stem fields
i think that universities
not colleges necessarily
i think that universities do more harm
than good now
that and i'm very
loath to say that you know because i've
been
part of the academy for 30 years and
taught a
great institutions
but
the
the postmodern
collectivist doctrine is so
psychologically and politically toxic
that i think
that
academia now does more harm than good
and it's not only what it teaches which
is the ideology this ungrateful ideology
which denies the existence of the
individual
one of the things i might tell you just
so you know this is that
you know that you hear
that there are debates about free speech
on campus
about who should talk and who shouldn't
and people think that's what the debate
is about
about who should talk and who shouldn't
but that's not what the debate is about
that you're not even scraping the
surface of the debate if that's what you
think it's about
the debate on campus is about whether or
not a human being has the capacity to
communicate
intelligibly as an individual or not
and the answer for the post-modernist
collective types is that there is no
such thing as an individual
and therefore the very notion of free
speech is absurd
because free speech is predicated on the
idea that each of us have something to
say that's ours that's a consequence of
our unique individuality not our group
identity or or the multiplicity of our
group identities but something that
that's
something that we have that speaks from
our spirit
that can speak to the spirit of another
and produce a negotiated
peace
and that's what's
being debated
that the war that's going on
philosophically or theologically in the
campuses is far deeper than you think it
though the entire notion of
the reality of the individual which is i
think also the entire notion of the idea
that human beings are made in the image
of god most fundamentally that
is what's being attacked it wasn't for
nothing that dereda
called western culture fell logo-centric
phallus for masculine logos for logos
for truth and courage and centric for
centric that was a criticism from his
perspective
the idea of the sovereignty of the
individual if you don't have the idea of
the sovereignty of the individual
because there's no individual there's no
free speech
all you are is an avatar of your group
interests and if i'm not in your group
it's not in my interest to let you speak
there's nothing that we have to say to
one another there's nothing but power
it's a hobbsian nightmare of group
against group
and that's the postmodern doctrine
and so
it's to call it appalling is to barely
scrape the surface it's it's an assault
it is it is truly
an assault on the most fundamental
principles by which the west is governed
it's not surface level philosophy
it goes all the way to the bottom
this is partly why i've been
concentrating on religious themes in my
lectures let's say
because
the argument goes all the way down to
first principles
is there
is the in is the idea of the sovereignty
of the individual
correct
the western answer is it's the great
discovery of the west the western answer
is that's the most fundamental truth
that is exactly what's under assault at
the universities the reason that the
collectivist types hate me
is because i've got their number
i know what they're up to
and i think i think further that
[Music]
they do not wish to shoulder the
unbearable responsibility
of being a sovereign individual
so not only
is it
and that accounts for the cowardice and
that accounts for the attempt to weaken
the spirit of the people that they're
teaching by over protecting them
they're not willing to take on the
responsibility it and the fault has to
lie elsewhere
and i think that's a good judge of
someone
someone's character in general it's like
well the world is in a messy state let's
say
and the question is whose fault is it
and the answer is
yours
that's the right answer
it's not
the patriarchy it's not
some identifiable group it's not some
structure that's gone wrong even though
those things can go wrong and that's the
other fundamental
truth of the west
is that
things would be a lot better if you were
a lot better
and you have to decide if you're willing
to accept that and and it you have every
reason not to it's a terrible thought
you know
with solzhenitsyn i think
this is a paraphrase but it's close
enough he said that one person who
stopped lying could bring down a tyranny
and that that
when i first read that i thought that
can't possibly be true and as i
understood it i thought that can't
possibly not be true
because the only thing that can
break the spine of a tyranny is the
truth and the only person that
and the only
way that the truth can be told is that
some individual tells it
and so it's necessarily the case that
tyranny is broken by the truth of the
individual
but then the question is well is it
going to be you that's going to do that
it's no trivial thing you know people
come and tell me
very frequently and they write me and
they say well you know i agree with what
you say and this terrible thing is
happening in my workplace and you know i
don't know what to do about it and i
don't want you to make my story public
and because of the potential for
repercussions and i think yeah well i
mean i understand your position it's no
joke to
it's no joke to stand up when when when
the
when they when the amateur totalitarians
are knocking on your office door
but if you don't then
sooner
sooner than you think it'll be the
professional totalitarians and then
you'll be in this sort of trouble that
that
unless you've tried to imagine it you
can't possibly imagine
so
in the uh minutes remaining
i'm going to uh ask a few personal
questions
uh as i did
with the late great charles krauthammer
at one of our weekends
because people like
including me just fascinated so here's
one
what was the city in alberta you grew up
in
well it wasn't a city
exactly it was a little town it was
called it's called fairview
it's about 800 miles north of the
american border so it's a long ways up
there right
so how often if at all
do you think
when people stop you at airports and go
around the world lecturing
jordan peterson from fairview
it's hard to believe
does that happen
well i live i live in a constant state
of disbelief i mean
i'm dead serious about this like i think
it's a form of post-traumatic
post-traumatic shock in some sense
i mean my life in the last three years
has been
just a
continual series of surreal
impossibilities
i mean
on the one hand
i've been involved in a political
scandal of some sort
for for a good year and a half it was at
least twice a week
and then for the entire three year
period it's been at least once a week
it's non-stop and sometimes it's
national
and sometimes it's international but
it's continual and so that's
i'll give you an example this is a funny
little story
my son came over one day about a year
and a half ago
and i was having a kind of a rough day
because 200 of my colleagues at the
university had signed a document
trying to get me fired
and then they gave it to the union and
and the union presented it to the
administration without even informing me
even though i'm part of the faculty
union
and so i said to my son
julian um
you know 200 of my colleagues today just
signed a letter saying that i should be
fired and he said
oh dad don't don't worry about that it
was only 200.
and i thought well that's where we were
at you know it was like oh
that's not that's that's that's a that
was a light day
that was okay you know and then so so
there's that and and the fact that it
doesn't quit that's another thing i
can't understand it's like you know all
this blew up around me around bill c-16
and i thought
well i've had my 15 minutes or my then
it was like well i've had my week and
then it was like oh
i must have had my month and then
but none of that happened it just kept
expanding and expanding and expanding
and expanding and expanding and and
every day i wake up and i think well
this is gonna come to an end but it
doesn't it just expands and
and that just doesn't seem credible in
the least every time i come to an event
like this or i mean when i was in
australia i was speaking to audiences of
5 500 people and it's like
how in the world can you believe that
it's like i you heard what i just said
who the who in their right mind would
come and listen to someone who just told
you what i told you you know it's so
dark and it's so demanding you wouldn't
think that people would
line up for blocks and
spend their hard-earned money and
and come because it's a like a marital
anniversary
that's what they say this was our
anniversary present to each other i
thank you people you admire completely
out of your mind
and so
and then i think too you know that that
that the state of disbelief is necessary
and maybe that's an advantage to being
older because i'm too old to adapt
rapidly
and this isn't the sort of thing that
you should adapt to right i should be in
a constant state of
shock disbelief because it keeps my head
on straight
i don't know what's going on exactly i
don't know why it's
the case that what i'm saying is so
necessary apparently
but it seems to be
and i'm trying to figure out why
but i'm certainly not for a second
i think i take very little for granted
and i i mean i think i take even less
for granted than you might think i told
you that i don't take it for granted
that you can all sit here peacefully you
know and and i i i and that is how i
look at the world is that if if it isn't
if it isn't
burning in rack and runes
then i think it's a bloody miracle
and the fact that things have gone
well for me
and that i'm still standing
which is also a miracle of sorts you
know i mean
there were probably
30 different scandalous
episodes
that had every
that anyone with any sense would have
thought would finish me
and
they've all backfired
and that's also
[Applause]
i also don't understand that it's like
i don't understand that
i get attacked in new york times
and my friends call me who are new york
times readers and they say
you you you you've had it this time
because that was the new york times you
know
you're not going to recover from that
and i think well that's probably true i
mean i was expecting it
to happen all along and then
i wait and then you know
everybody clamors at me and then
i don't respond too much to that and
starts to die away and then all the
supporters come out and then there's
a hundred people who clamor and 10 000
supporters
and you know here's something i can tell
you about my life
that's really remarkable
so
you know if you
just read
the press
well you'd have all sorts of ideas about
me
i mean
you know that i'm a bigot
in the broadest possible sense and so
that's you know racist sexist
homophobic ethnocentric
white nationalist alt-right
islamophobic homophobic all of those
things
and you'd think that there was just
nothing but hatred
although i have been treated well by
many journalists but you you could
easily get that sense that like i live
in a world
where i'm surrounded by hatred and that
is absolutely not true
it's so not true that that that it's
you know there are lies and then there
are there are there are anti-truths
and an anti-truth is even worse than a
lie
it's like the ultimate form of lie and
that is what my life is like at all
what my life is like is that
i travel with my wife
and wherever we go
and i mean that literally wherever we go
we've been to i don't know how many
countries in the last year it's like
i don't know how many
30 40
many countries
if i go down the street
or if i'm in an airport or if i'm in a
cafe or if i'm in a movie theater or if
i'm in a
mechanics shop
[Music]
some person comes up to me
every 10 minutes and says
i hope i'm not disturbing you and
they're very very polite
and they say
i've been listening to your lectures or
i've been watching your youtube videos
or i read your book
and
i was in this dreadful place
six months ago and then they tell me a
little bit about
the particulars of that little corner of
hell they were ensconced in and then
they say well i've been trying to
develop a vision for my life
or i've been trying to take more
responsibility i've been trying to be
grateful for my job
mundane though it may be
or i've decided that i'm going to try to
put my family together and make peace
and i've really been trying and it's
really working
and things are way better
and
thank you
and so
well it's
it's overwhelming to have that happen
continually it's very difficult to
believe
but
it's unbelievably positive
you know i mean it's if you could
imagine if you could ask for what you
wanted day
you could have anything you wanted
you might think
it would be lovely if i could live my
life in a manner so that
wherever i went in the world
perfect strangers would come up to me
one after the other
and tell me
that
they're suffering much less
that their families are in better shape
and that their lives are on course
because they took
they
they took to heart some
something that i was communicating
that's as good as it gets
as far as i can tell
[Applause]
i really i don't want to ask anything
else
i think this was so powerful
and if that didn't prove my instinct is
right
nothing will jordan peterson
you are a good man
you are doing a lot of good
i thank god he made you
thank you
[Applause]